don't go raise my spirit back welcome to
the fair rest every time the game
updates you have to restart everything
so far which is a little annoying Bay
what are you gonna do Timmy you little
[ __ ] why did you have to go missing Oh
God
Timmy Timmy hold my hand I'm scared
Timmy you did this didn't you
Timmy you're controlling by the devil
God gave it to me I know there was
something wrong when you were [ __ ]
on the floor like that there is supposed
to be a new item in the plane so um hi
there so I'm curious about that they
have a lot of those magazines man what
is it breathe don't tell me what to do
you [ __ ] alright they're supposed to be
secret item what does that mean is that
a PSP that's cellphone oh all right I
can see how many steps I've taken that's
very useful cuz I was just wondering
that the other day how many steps I've
taken in the game let's set up on your
base alright you can build the the log
cabinet now so I'm pretty curious to
check that out I just have to find the
water I want to stay by the water you
know what if I had a cellphone I
wouldn't be wasting my battery on this
[ __ ] step counter but hey this is me
oh we got a one of these you wanna you
want the stick you want it you want it
poke you poke you if this was Facebook
this would be a different thing this
area is such a good place for a oh god
oh god what happened here this tables
are all filled with blood oh my god this
is horrible
Oh Oh God I don't like this this is
really scary even though it's [ __ ]
day in [ __ ] that's pretty badass sound
effect they added alright this seems
like a good place let's set camp here
what are you guys doing I missed you man
come on die all right that's right stay
there stay there oh man what kind of
world are we living and you can't even
[ __ ] kill someone with a leg come
back here pants I hate you you always
cook my that's what you get for running
come on Lizzy come a wrap
pretty good I missed you man there we go
we're back in business baby a house a
houseboat a houseboat that's amazing arm
effigy oh my god that's so cool let's
feel like I only have one arm but
whatever this game is so much fun man I
can't I don't even know why pick it up
that bap bap bap never seen it shut up
but you said it like five times
there we go let's fill our army let me
reload I may for you but I'm moving on
AVG beautiful my mom was right I really
have a great sense of fashion and design
we should probably set up a camp let's
do a temporarily shelter I don't want to
I don't want to you know there we go we
have our B it's so tiny I look like
gonna sleep in there look I could take
it for my foot in there this is a foot
shelter this is a better [ __ ] camp
than that
I'm sorry Lizzie but you gotta go y'all
pouch place don't call me I'm your only
friend remember now get damn it you're
right all right but I'm really hungry
though
come on birds you couldn't do anything
without me all right fine
let's find some stuff to kill I guess
this is blueberries is are they safe to
eat Lizzie I'm sure all right
yeah they help with the hunger a little
bit cool
you seem it seems like you get hungry
hungry faster now leave us alone please
this is my shelter all right and your
this is my private I'm sorry but this is
my foot shelter please kindly back the
[ __ ] off okay that that's just mean all
right Oh
that's what you got free oh you idiot oh
my god what a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's the
best thing ever
alright let's sleep so we save at least
oh god we've really [ __ ] need food I
can't even go to sleep I have three
Lizzie otherwise I'm gonna die
Lizzie I'm sorry
don't do it at daylight belt I'm sorry
I'm so sorry
let's see look at my I'm sorry look how
hungry I am I might just storm while
waiting for this to cook
hurry up getting cooked Lizzie oh I'm
sorry
come on cook already eat oh thank god
Lizzie I I will remember you forever
LaCie 2014 this game just made me really
sad
all I wanted was to live on a houseboat
with my Lizzie in fact too much to ask
why do you test me let's build another
beautiful effigy small effigy simple
effigy that sounds fantastic
you'll be my friend bang you're on
you're on scared
you're on your you're on hello you're on
there you go you're beautiful what are
you doing on your on ha I don't work to
me you [ __ ] bird Oh
oh my god
alright hey Lizzie hi there I love aids
I came back from Hell thank you for
doing that
appreciate it alright since we now have
a tiny supply of fishes and an arm for
some reason to scratch my back of course
I think we can start working on a bigger
project we never actually build a log
cabin n80 [ __ ] - alright that'll be a
project um my lumberjack Oh a moku I eat
sleep all night and I work all day oh my
god
how much more it's oh my god I want that
bunny I want you [ __ ] get wreaked huh -
choo choo choo choo come here quick Mike
went well [ __ ] gate break
you got Nate
Oh 41 - like I'm almost up with a large
one I'm Amazon I have a tennis ball
let's throw it at him see what happens
hey oh oh here right away
the power of the tennis ball is god I
can't believe this piece of [ __ ] is
almost funny late on this product was a
dumb idea
it's to grow longer ah sorry God I mean
it was a great idea no no leave me alone
[ __ ] don't you see my trophies don't
you know what happened
one more chem on now you are the last
puzzle piece breath don't you dare come
in my way but it says it's finished
come here let's say that's not your
class ah shut up I need to kill you
ain't nobody stand away from me and my
log cabinet twenty-two more I was so
happy
twenty-two well I didn't come this far
to stop now
Oh God what the [ __ ] was that whoa what
the [ __ ] happened there
Jesus that's my Lizzy later life he saw
me kill listen he's like oh I don't [ __ ]
with that game taste it taste it taste
it don't taste it then he climbed a try
ohh ohh ohh ohh ohh have fun up there I
hope you're having a great time up there
chop it down all right all right I guess
you're dead Oh most done I'm wearing
Lizzie I'm wearing Lizzie Lizzie sinuous
fashion a Muslim let's kill you Edna but
that when you're friends you always
check your facebook profile then yeah
I'm sorry I gave your mother or you win
this round where's the bunny come on
come on I won't hurt you I will just
murder you brutally all right sorry
Lizzie Oh to the slow one [ __ ] almost
done six more logs baby no one's gonna
stop me
Oh Oh get a lake get raked how do I
enter my house oh my god I have I have
to breathe my favorite pillow and
touching oh my god is this the best
[ __ ] house get off my house now it's
time for now wait never mind I changed
my mind I changed my mind I changed my
mind
all right let's kill let's kill them
where are they I saw them I am Not
Afraid you I am the gang yet what it
went through him oh I feel like burning
I hope you like painful deaths cuz
that's just what happened
give me his head I want his head I don't
want no [ __ ] leg and [ __ ] I want his
[ __ ] head
where's her head what's that they could
fly everywhere am I supposed to keep
track of them
boy you want to build a snowman you are
all [ __ ] dead I [ __ ] hate you all
of you you are [ __ ] dead you're not
an octopus Oh
although he doesn't even give a [ __ ]
where's the head darkness yes Oh two
heads
Oh are we done with the bird food and
Fergie oh come on two more seriously
Lizzy La Paz ahahaha but that's not even
English come here you little batch pods
no your cries i we used to be together
ah that's before I needed your arm or
you changed buds whoa I don't have time
look I have his [ __ ] head along my
deck just [ __ ] realize he's mine okay
Oh
beautiful it's up you wanna fall let's
go to sleep that was a great episode I
did we did a lot of [ __ ] but I gonna
have to end this episode here so go
ahead and leave a like for us I really
appreciate it and hits sky combo today
next time broke bad